los virus del papiloma humano también
denominados vph conforman un grupo de
más de un centenar de virus relacionados
que infectan a las personas la mayoría
de los de ph pueden causar verrugas
comunes de la piel generalmente en las
manos o los pies sin embargo unos 40
tipos de vph infectan a los genitales
que son los órganos sexuales en el
exterior del cuerpo éstos pph causan las
infecciones más comunes de transmisión
sexual enfermedades transmitidas de una
persona a otra a través de la actividad
sexual
algunos de ph genitales son de bajo
riesgo y solo pueden causar verrugas en
los genitales y el ano y alrededor de
estos de las mujeres y los hombres en
raras ocasiones estos pph también pueden
causar verrugas dentro de la boca y la
garganta otros de ph genitales son de
alto riesgo pueden producir cáncer en el
extremo inferior del útero de una mujer
denominado cuello uterino
con menos frecuencia estos vph pueden
producir otros cánceres genitales anales
u orales tanto en mujeres como en
hombres es importante saber que la
mayoría de las infecciones por vph no
causan síntomas y los de ph genitales de
bajo riesgo que causan las verrugas no
son una causa importante de cáncer
las personas infectadas ya sea con vph
genital de alto riesgo o de bajo riesgo
lo transmiten a través del contacto de
piel a piel durante el sexo vaginal anal
u oral para que ocurra la infección el
vph entra a través de pequeños cortes en
la piel alrededor o dentro de la vagina
o pene la garganta o el ano
el virus llega hasta las células en la
parte inferior o basal capa de la piel y
las infecta
como las células infectadas se dividen
el virus comienza a hacer copias de sí
mismo con el tiempo las células
infectadas se trasladan a través de las
capas de la piel y liberan nuevos virus
que pueden transmitir la infección a
otras células para la mayoría de la
gente las células del sistema inmune
pueden destruir a las células infectadas
junto con el virus dentro de los dos
años pero en algunas personas el sistema
inmune no es capaz de destruir todos los
virus dando lugar a una infección que no
desaparece
las células infectadas por vph pueden
multiplicarse durante varias semanas o
meses
si las células se infectan con vph de
bajo riesgo comienzan a formar verrugas
alrededor de los genitales
si el vph es de alto riesgo puede dañar
el material genético de las células
haciendo que las células se vuelvan pre
cancerosas durante un periodo de años un
tumor canceroso se puede formar
lentamente a medida que las células
dañadas continúan multiplicándose
el tipo de cáncer más común de vph
genital de alto riesgo es el cáncer de
cuello uterino
no hay cura para ningún tipo de
infección por vph sin embargo la vacuna
gardasil puede ayudar en la protección
contra dos de los bebé h de alto riesgo
más comunes que causan cánceres
genitales la vacuna también protege
contra dos de los bp h de bajo riesgo
más comunes que causan verrugas
genitales
para una mejor protección las niñas y
los niños preadolescentes deben recibir
tres dosis de la vacuna en un periodo de
seis meses antes de que participen de
cualquier actividad sexual
la vacuna inyecta proteínas muertas de
virus vph en el torrente sanguíneo estas
proteínas no causan infección
pero las proteínas estimulan a
determinadas células inmunitarias para
que creen marcadores denominados
anticuerpos que puedan identificar estos
bp h
más tarde si las versiones vivas de
estos virus invaden la piel los
anticuerpos las reconocen y se unen a
ellas
estas células inmunitarias destruyen los
virus marcados lo que impide que se
produzca una infección es importante
señalar que la vacuna no protege contra
otros tipos de vph no incluidos en la
vacuna
la vacuna tampoco trata de forma
confiable las células que ya están
infectadas
los de ph genitales de alto riesgo que
causan cáncer cervical son más tratables
cuando se diagnostican a tiempo las
mujeres deben hacerse una prueba de
papanicolaou para ver si su cuello
uterino tiene células anormales o pre
cancerosas incluso si han recibido una
vacuna contra el vph consulte con un
profesional de atención médica para
averiguar con qué frecuencia debe
realizarse esta prueba durante este
procedimiento el médico recolectar a una
pequeña muestra de células del cuello
uterino
estas células serán examinadas en un
microscopio para ver si son anormales o
cancerosas
otra prueba de vph buscará material
genético de los tipos de vph de alto
riesgo cuando una prueba de papanicolaou
y la prueba del vph se hacen juntas se
llama prueba conjunta si estas pruebas
muestran células anormales el medico
recomendará un tratamiento específico
según la edad de la mujer el historial
médico y la anomalía de sus células
aunque no existe una cura para la
infección por vph tanto las células
anormales como las cancerosas pueden ser
tratadas
algunos tipos de vph pueden causar
verrugas comunes de la piel o verrugas
genitales las verrugas pueden
desaparecer sin tratamiento a medida que
el sistema inmunológico combate la
infección por vph si las verrugas son
dolorosas o no desaparecen visite a un
médico para que pueda examinarlas a fin
de determinar la mejor manera de
eliminarlas aunque puede tratar las
verrugas comunes en su hogar no trate
las verrugas genitales usted mismo
los procedimientos para eliminar ya sea
verrugas comunes o verrugas genitales
son congelación con crioterapia
quemadura con corriente eléctrica
denominada electro cauterización
o extirpación quirúrgica
para obtener más información consulte a
un profesional de atención médica